les mac sont l invention ou découverte
en voilà une question passionnante
alors bien sûr un puriste pourra dire
que les deux cas sont en fait isomorphe
et que du coup la question importe peu
un peu comme l'ordre dans lequel on tire
les cartes dans une pioche pour mélanger
en fait non il ya une différence
fondamentale entre les mathématiques
dites classiques celles qui suivent les
pas de kantor gödel et bourbaki et les
mathématiques dit intuition liste ou
constructiviste ans c'est la même chose
celles qui suivent les pas de
chroniqueurs power et martin l'ofs
on y viendra pour l'heure j'aimerais
vous faire sentir qu'à défaut de
modifier la validité des théorèmes
mathématiques la manière d'aborder ses
théorèmes peut grandement modifié notre
ressenti nos intuitions et notre
appréciation des mathématiques et selon
les caractères des uns et des autres il
peut être plus excitant de penser que
l'on est en train d'explorer un univers
mathématiques dont on essaie de dénicher
des merveilles où il peut être plus
excitant de penser que l'on construit
des nouvelles structures mathématiques
tels des lego alors de façon grossière
on peut dire que de nombreux chercheurs
en mathématiques pures en géométrie en
analyse ou en algèbre ont tendance à
plutôt penser qu'il existe un monde
idéal des idées une platonicien où
vivent les concepts mathématiques et où
on peut se promener pour les découvrir
de l'autre côté des chercheurs en
mathématiques plus appliqués ou en
informatique théorique vont être plus
constructiviste dans la mesure où
l'existence des objets importe peu pour
eux ce qui importe c'est qu'on puisse
les construire à titre personnel ayant
grandi dans la pure tradition des
mathématiques de bourbaki j'ai longtemps
a été plutôt platonicien j'ai longtemps
cru à l'axiome du choix et j'ai
longtemps admiré les preuve par
l'absurde
cependant j'ai fait ma thèse en
mathématiques appliquées et la notion de
calcul habité s'est retrouvé au coeur de
nombre de mes réflexions
aujourd'hui j'ai plutôt tendance à
rejeter l'action du choix et les preuves
d'existence par l'absurde à cette
archive rcv n'osant différence
mathématique entre platonicien et
intuition nist
on peut résumer le coeur du débat à la
loi du tiers exclu cette règle de la
logique stipule qu'une proposition ou
bien vrai ou bien fausse autrement dit
en langage formel on à x ou non x il n'y
a pas de troisième possibilité en
particulier la loi duty a exclu affirme
qu'un théorème qui n'est pas faux est
forcément vrai c'est cette affirmation
qui irrite tant les intuitions nist pour
un intuition liste au final la véracité
d'un théorème on s'en fout la question
qui importe c est ce qu'on peut
construire une preuve du théorème
ceci est particulièrement le cas lorsque
l'on cherche à prouver l'existence de
certains objets on en a vu plusieurs
exemples dans les épisodes précédents et
je vous propose d'en étudier considérons
le théorème suivant il existe au moins
un chiffre qui apparaît une infinité de
fois dans les décimales de toronto et
d'offrir on peut prouver ce théorème par
l'abe suivante supposons que tous les
chiffres apparaissent tous un nombre
fini deux fois alors le nombre de
décimales du taux sera la somme des
nombres d'apparition des différents
chiffres qui est un nombre fini donc tôt
à un nombre fini de décimales et ça
c'est absurde tôt à un nombre infini de
décimales notre supposition initial
était une fausse on a ainsi prouvé qu'il
existait au moins un chiffre qui
apparaît une infinité de fois le
théorème est donc vrai oui mais l'un du
sioniste sans ballack
ce qui lui importe c'est de déterminer
un chiffre qui en effet apparaît une
infinité de fois dans les décimales de
tose ça pour lui qui importent lorsque
l'on dit l'expression il existe c'est on
peut en effet déterminé le chiffre en
question et du coulin tous unis va
regarder la preuve de plus près il va se
demander si à partir de cette preuve on
est capable de la modifier et d'exhiber
un chiffre qui en effet est solution de
la question que l'on se pose est
initialement et dans notre cas ce n'est
pas possible ce n'est pas possible de
partir de la preuve et d'exhiber un
chiffre qui en effet va pas être une
infinité de fois dont les décimales de
taux et ça pour un impressionniste ça
veut dire que la preuve que l'on a donné
ne sert à rien autre exemple considérant
le théorème qui dit qu'il existe deux
irrationnelle xy tels que x puissance y
est rationnel
voyons sont une preuve classique
rappelons que racine carrée de 2 est un
nombre irrationnel je vous mets la
preuve de cela en petit mais du coup si
racine carrée de deux puissances racine
carrée de deux étaient nombreux
rationnel on peut poser x est égal à y
est égal à racine carrée de deux et on a
une solution du théorème dans le cas
contraire posons x est égal à racine
carrée de deux puissances racine carrée
de 2 et y est égale racine carrée de 2
on a alors x puissance y est égale
racine carrée de deux puissances racine
carrée de 2
le tout à la puissance hrazem carré de 2
qui est égale racine carrée de deux
puissances racine carrée de deux fois
racine carrée de 2 qui est égale à la
racine carrée de 2 ou carey qui est égal
à 2 du coup x et y sont encore des
solutions au théorème
dans les deux cas on a bien une solution
intègre m situé à st
oui mais laquelle des deux solutions
proposées est effectivement une solution
du théorème l'intuition nice tu trouves
la preuve incomplète car elle ne permet
pas d'exhiber uniquement une solution
concrète du problème elle dit seulement
que parmi deux solutions au moins une
est juste mais ne précise pas laquelle
l'intuition nist préférera largement une
preuve qui sera beaucoup plus
constructive par exemple qui posera x et
galeux et y est égal au le gag né paie
rien de 2 ou mieux encore x est égal à
racine carrée de 2 et y est égale à deux
fois le logarithme de 3 en baisse de la
capacité d'une preuve à construire
aisément et efficacement une solution du
problème est un problème intéressant en
tant que tel et l'intuition nist par
ainsi discriminer des preuves plus ou
moins constructive en particulier les
antisionistes va le constamment cherché
à transformer des preuves non
constructives ont des preuves
constructive et ses preuves
constructives ont ensuite donné lieu à
des algorithmes qui pourront avoir une
certaine utilité en pratique par exemple
on peut prouver le fait qu'il existe une
infinité de nombreux premiers par
l'absurde parfois même en une ligne
cependant il est bien de plus
intéressant de construire un algorithme
qui va chercher de nouveaux nombreux
promis pour ce faire on peut adapter la
preuve classique d'euclide supposons que
l'on a construit un ensemble paix de
nombreux premiers pour en construire
d'autres
on peut multiplier tous les nombres
premiers de l'ensemble paix et ajouter
un aux résultats puis chercher les
diviseurs du nombre que l'on a obtenue
par construction ces diviseurs ne
peuvent pas être les nombreux premier de
l'ensemble p on obtient ainsi des
nombres premiers n'avaient pas encore
été listées dans l'ensemble p voilà une
façon de construire des ensembles
toujours plus grand de nombreux premiers
et qui montre au passage qu'il y en a
donc une infinité cependant l'intuition
nist pourra rajouter que la preuve que
l'on a fourni la si elle est
parfaitement valide
elle conduit à des temps de calcul est
extrêmement lent et que l'on pourrait
sans doute faire beaucoup mieux pour
construire d'autres nombreux produits en
pratique en fait il s'agit d'un premier
ouvert que de trouver un algorithme
performant qui construit toujours plus
de nombreux profs bref j'espère vous
avoir fait sentir la différence entre
les mathématiques platonicienne et
mathématiques intuition nice n'a vu
qu'il s'agissait d'une différence dans
l'appréciation des preuves de leur
utilité mais il ya aussi nos différences
plus fondamental qui est d'ailleurs lié
au théorème d'incomplétude de gödel
souvenez-vous j'avais dit que dell avait
réussi à construire un théorème g qui
dit que j'ai n'a pas de preuves on peut
alors utiliser un raisonnement
platonicien pour prouver que j'ai est
forcément vrai pour cela on suppose par
l'absurde que j'ai est faux or si j' ai
faut ça veut dire que son énoncé est
faux et du coup ça veut dire que le
théorème g à une preuve mais si j'ai à
une preuve c'est que j'ai est vrai et ça
c'est bien sûr en contradiction avec
l'hypothèse selon laquelle j'ai et faut
donc notre postulat de base est faux ça
veut dire que j'ai n'est pas faux et
donc j'ai est vrai mais n'a pas de
preuve si vous trouvez cette explication
obscures vous n'êtes pas le seul elle
est juste elle est bizarre pour les
antisionistes la bonne interprétation du
théorème de gödel est beaucoup plus
simple l'intuition liste se moquent
complètement des notions de vrais ou de
faux ce qui lui importe c'est est-ce que
ça a une preuve voir tout ce que le
raisonnement par l'absurde que l'on
vient de faire montre c'est que si j'ai
à une preuve alors la théorie et
inconsistantes
c'est tout ce qu'il reste à espérer pour
l'intuition liste c'est qu'on n'arrivera
jamais à construire une preuve de g
voilà qui me semble beaucoup plus simple
et beaucoup moins métaphysiquement
farfelue que l'interprétation classique
vous l'aurez compris j'ai choisi mon
camp et ça c'est pas mal ressentie tout
au long de cette vidéo je vous ai en
gros donner des bonnes raisons d'être
intuition nice
cependant il faut bien avouer que des
pans entiers des mathématiques
s'effondre dès lors que l'on rejette le
tiers exclu à commencer par ceux que
l'on croyait savoir des nombres réels
en particulier en l'absence du tiers
exclu le théorème des valeurs
intermédiaires n'a plus de preuves or ce
théorème paraît intuitivement évident si
je trace une courbe qui traverse une
droite c'est à dire qu'au début elle
commence en bas de la droite est elle
finie au de la droite
alors forcément quelque part la courbe
interceptera la droite
ça paraît clairement vrai nom non la
preuve classique de ce théorème est une
preuve par dichotomie elle nous dit de
prendre le milieu de la courbe
si ce milieu est au dessus on va se
concentrer sur la partie gauche de la
courbe
et sinon on va se concentrer sur la
partie de droite et on répète ainsi de
suite cette dichotomie jusqu'à ce que
nos deux bornes convergent en un unique
point où la courbe couple à droite
a priori cette preuve classique paraît
complètement constructive puisqu'elle
nous permet de construire un fim et un
point d'intersection là où la logique
intuition liste est assez bizarre c'est
qu'il se peut que la dichotomie soit 1
conclusive notre point du milieu pour
être ni probablement en dessous de la
droite ni probablement au dessus de la
droite ni probablement sur la droite
la loi du tiers exclu est en effet
nécessaire pour affirmer qu'un point et
soit en dessous soit au dessus soit sur
la droite sont logiques intuition nist
il existe une quatrième option il se
peut qu aucune de ces trois options ni
de preuves
et oui c'est bizarre et ce n'est que
l'une des très nombreuses bizarreries
les mathématiques inclus sioniste mais
pour devenir intentionnistes il faut
finir par l'accepter une courbe peut
traverser une droite sans jamais la
couper mais à la fin on a parlé des
isomorphisme et jojo fifou du coup nous
demande s'il ya un iso morphisme entre
les notations partir et elle est partie
imaginaire des nombres complexes et les
notations module arguments alors en fait
pas tout à fait parce que la notation en
modules argument n
ne marche pas tout à fait pour elle à
une singularité pour le point zéro
puisqu'il ya plusieurs façons en fait
notamment de représenter l'argument du
point qui correspond à l'origine du plan
complexe mais plus généralement la
partie réelle et la partie imaginaire ça
c'est complètement idiot mars déjà au
plan ça ce qui est quand même assez
remarquable c'est pour ça que l'on parle
du plan complexe le plan complexe c'est
la même chose que les nombres complexes
en fait de quoi leur donner le même nom
et la notation module arguments on peut
voir ça comme le plan complexe - le
point central lorsqu'on prend en tout
cas des modules strictement positif
alors il existe un isomorphisme un peu
plus cacher aussi entre les nombres
complexes que l'on peut additionner
classiquement un pull zippé et les
nombres complexes en huit étapes dans la
manière terminent tout peut les
multiplier à travers ce qu'on pourrait
appeler l'expo nantiat sion puisque
l'expo n'en ciation permet de
transformer l'addition en multiplication
alors il s'agit pas tout à fait dans le
miso mon fils mais dans ce cas là mais
dans le cas pardon si on prend juste les
nombres réels avec l'addition ça ça va
être isomorphe nombre réel de ce
traitement positif avec la
multiplication et 7 isomorphisme qu'il y
as entre ces deux espaces
donc pour être plus précise salir ni
zoomorphisme de groupes ordonnée et 7
iseo morphisme là il est super important
dans l'histoire des mathématiques
puisqu'il a permis notamment de faire
des multiplications avec des tables ce
qu'on appelle logarithmique donc de
façon beaucoup plus simple et je vous
renvoie vers la vidéo de nick maths qui
a pas mal parlé notamment de la
différence d'un côté entre le monde al
hiti fait le monde médiatique et d'autre
part
bien parlé aussi du logar et antoine
bensalah nous fait leur marque lorsque
l'on construit les nombres complexes
d'habitude pendant ma pause et ça comme
étant r3 est gros et faute de réelle
pour décrire un nombre complexe mais du
coup un nombre réel n'est pas un nombre
complexe si on fait ça stricto sensu
c'est à dire l'ensemble des nombres
réels n'est pas un sous-ensemble dans ce
cas de l'ensemble des nombres complexes
et donc moi je me suis en tout cas on
peut pas en parler de l'injection
canonique de l'ensemble des nombres
réels dans son complexe
bon c'est ça c'est des gros mots pour
juste dire que du coup on va essayer de
pousser avec un nombre réel quand même à
l'intérieur d'un nombre de l'ensemble de
nos complexes
vous voyez que si on raisonne purement
d'un point de vue théorie des ensembles
tout ça c'est un petit peu bancal c'est
pas très clair et la raison pour
laquelle on peut quand même se permettre
de dire qu'un nombre réel est un nombre
complexe
c'est en vertu de la notion disons
morphisme en disant que nous sommes le
des nombres réels et isomorphe avec un
certain sous-ensembles des nombres
complexes et 7 isomorphisme une
objection canonique c'est à dire que
d'ensemble et nombre réel va être inclus
va être isomorphe un sous-ensemble de
l'ensemble des nombres complexes c'est
ce qu'on appelle une injection pour les
canonique canonique juste dire truc
évident on truque on pouvait pas faire
autrement et c'est cette injection
canonique 7 isomorphisme ans entre
l'ensemble des nombres réels et un
sous-ensemble des nombres complexes qui
nous permet de dire qu' un nombre réel
est un nombre complexe
donc c'est un abus de langage de dire ça
mais c'est un abus de langage que l'on
peut se permettre en vertu de la
citation de poincaré
erwan dark vador me fait la remarque que
lui de brogues lieu ce prince en fait
lui de bruit tu imagines que je suis pas
le premier à déclencher son noir dans
avec un nom comme ça
sofiane hanni fait nous demandent
pourquoi est ce que la notion 10 au mort
fils mais est plus importante que la
notion de direction pourquoi est-ce
qu'une direction ne suffit pas bien
c'est parce que lorsqu'on parle de dison
morphisme on a envie d'inclure un peu
plus une certaine structure donc par
exemple si je prend l'ensemble 01 perçu
seul ensemble vrai ou faux une déjection
évidente entre les deux mais ce qui va
être intéressant c est ce que l'on peut
faire exactement tout ce que l'on peut
faire avec vrai ou faux avec 0,1
par exemple avec vrai ou faux on envie
de dire que vrais et faux par exemple ça
fait faux alors que vraie ou fausse à
fait vrai mais petite règle comme ça
brasse en gare de 0,1 avec les
opérations d'addition et de
multiplication
modulo 2 par exemple mais on voit que
vrai ou faux avec les opérations et où
et 0,1 avec les opérations plus et x ne
sont pas du tout mise à mort se
comportent pas du tout de la même façon
en revanche si on commence à regarder 0
1 avec des opérateurs comme le minimum
entre deux au reniement et le maximum là
on voit que 0,1 va se comporter tout
tacot exactement de la même façon que
vrai ou faux ou le minimum va être
remplacé par le ix et le maximum va être
remplacé par le houx et du coup là on a
vraiment on peut vraiment traiter la
logique du vrai ou faux de la même façon
que l'on peut traiter des beats 0 1 avec
des opérations de minimum est de maximum
donc c'est cette isomorphisme qui est
vraiment intéressant et qui ont
notamment permis de faire les
ordinateurs bref au wake est énorme et
ont énormément d'exemple disons
morphisme et j'espère que c'est quelque
chose de vraiment jouissif
les dépôts mer enfin je vous avais posé
un mini défier dans l'épisode précédent
dans les commentaires des épisodes
précédents
2010les consistait à écrire dans la
géométrie de tarse qui danse est clos
maîtrise formelle du premier ordre
le fait que deux angles étaient égaux et
ceux des filles a été brillamment relevé
par mick 2048 donc c'est la formule
qu'il a écrit quelque part par là
l'idée c'est que deux angles vont être
egos si lorsque je construis des ce
triangle isocèle le semblable à partir
donc dont les côtés ego sont ceux qui
sont liées au sommet en question dont on
cherche la mesure et l'angle si on a
deux triangle isocèle donc de côté son
ego alors l'angle entre ces deux côtés
va être le même si et seulement si le
côté opposé à cet angle pas être égal
bref ça correspond à cette formule a
donc fait citation mikit 2048 j'espère
que vous avez aimé cette vidéo avec toi
on va parler des cardinaux infinie
maison logique un tuyau nist on va voir
que ça correspond pas du tout à tout ce
que vous racontez à la fois à l'école et
sur internet notamment
quelqu'un vous aviez des grosses
conneries ou en tout cas les frais qui
sont pas du tout valable en logique
inflationniste et si c'est pas valable
logique intentionnistes c'est son autre
que c'est pas du tout pertinente si vous
avez aimé cet épisode essentielle de
l'ikea le commentaire et de partage et
pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas
manquer les futurs épisodes merci aux
outils performants et j'espère que je
verrai la prochaine fois mais si on
regarde plus précisément cette règle qui
nous permet de le montrer aoun loin dans
tous les cas c'est à dire sans savoir si
la proposition à evreux ou si elle est
fausse
eh bien on entre ici avec cette règle dû
tirer dessus déjà dans une situation
dans laquelle on dit ou bien une
situation et brel ou bien une autre
situation des brêles sans savoir de
laquelle de la situation et par la crise
existe